cover that in cases matt skilton from
angus in scotland was nervous about
sending his daughters back to school as
will be the case across the uk for 13
year old keris there are no more class
or year bubbles and fewer covered rules
the fact that they're not vaccinated
and actually a number of the population
still aren't vaccinated is a real
concern and having looked at how things
are happening elsewhere even with high
vaccination
etc in the population
things opening up being a little bit
more relaxed really concerned
and the effects of things like long
covered
scotland's covert cases have doubled in
a week and when you drill down into the
data you can see a major reason why
cases amongst young people 19 and under
decreased during the summer break but
here you can see just how quickly they
spiked again once schools went back
the government is very reluctant to
reimpose restrictions i'm hoping things
will settle down the more vaccines we
can deliver and the more difference they
will make but it's a tricky situation in
scotland at the moment i think it's
important to test so that you can
protect your friends and your family
this isn't the news the department for
education wanted their major new
campaign is about encouraging parents to
feel safe and sending their kids back to
the classroom
but in their latest report the
government's own scientific advisors
predict a surge in cases
sage forecasts exponential increases in
covert cases once all schools are back
with a high prevalence by the end of
september for which they say it would be
sensible for government to plan for
now you might be thinking why does this
all matter after all we've had a mass
vaccination programme the majority of
vulnerable people are all double dosed
but a new study has shown that the delta
variant which is now the most prominent
in the uk is more than twice as likely
to result in severe illness than
previous variants so there's the public
health impact but also the general
impact of more miss schooling if
children are catching covid as well as
the consequences for their parents or
carers
vaccine experts are now taking a
cautious but considerable look at covert
vaccines for all 12 to 15 year olds with
nhs england possibly timing a roll out
for the reopening of schools some ask
why not earlier why not everywhere in
lieu of vaccinations scientists say
regular mass testing will be key to keep
schools open and keep communities safe
katrina patosi sky news